e
um sorry for the slight delay and make
some copies
um since we last met as a subcommittee
um representative infantine and myself
um met with the Department of Labor um
and uh had a very uh in-depth um
conversation they had done a lot of work
done a lot of research
and um they uh had offered us uh two
options for an amendment and I intended
to have an actual Amendment today but um
and and you you folks are great about
getting some something to us on Monday
but uh OS seems to be to be busy with
800 um
lsrs um so uh I I did not get the
Amendments yet um but at any rate this
this is uh nicely done by the attorneys
with the Department of Labor and it
effectively provides two
options and
uh the the first
option um basically adopts the um
1910 um uh standards um D through Z with
the exception of U um and it um is
adopted um three years from now um the
idea is to give um every everyone who
needs it including the department uh
plenty of time for um the uh preparation
um to to learn the standards to deal
with whatever needs to be deal dealt
with and um and basically the department
would um be putting on additional um
Personnel in order to help the uh the
the employers um with with the
transition so um it seemed to be a more
workable manner of adopting the 1910
standards um providing that three-year
everyone that's option
one option two um is
um a little bit different it comes out
of the uh Department as a alternative
and a
essentially instead of adopting 1910
1910 as written by um
OSHA it uses 1910 as a think it's fair
to say as a guide um and that the
department over the course of three
years would engage in rul making that
would um come up with standards that are
at least um as effective as the OSHA
standards um so basically all those gaps
that are that exist in the current um
department of labor standards would be
filled um using OSHA as a guide as to
um they would basically take those three
years um to to do that
um one difference is that they probably
would not need as many um uh additional
employees for for the ramp up um their
thought is that the U the standards
would be at least as effective but
perhaps easier to um to read and so um
employers who are going through the
the the standards that are developed
through Ru making will have an easier
time figuring out exactly what they need
to do um but they still have that
three-year window um to get ready
anybody who wants to get ahead of the
department can simply use the 1910
standards to um say okay what what's
still coming um it also gives them the
authority to skip some sections um if
there's a section that does not apply to
any public sector employer in the state
um if if it deals with mining or
something like that um there's no need
to have standards for um safe standards
around around mining for um uh you know
public sector workers in New Hampshire
um but any section that does is
applicable to the public sector workers
in New Hampshire would have rules that
um also provides for an annual review of
of Standards so that um as o if OSHA
upgrades its standards the department
would um uh write rules to reflect those
upgrades um so that it remains at least
standards and it also indicates that um
the commissioner May seek additional
Staffing um that Staffing would be paid
um out of the um the funds that the
department has on hand um but it would
need to get author authorization to use
those funds for that additional Staffing
um and I guess I would ask uh chairman
infantine if he's got if I if I've
missed anything and frankly I'll be
happy to hear from the um the department
well representative Sullivan no I I I
don't have any uh comments about what
you said you you've stated you know
correctly as per our our meeting with
the Department um really what it comes
down to is trying to implement something
that is manageable to both the
department Municipal and government
um bodies and the employees um that
serve on you know that that that are
within those departments
um you know my my concern has always
been um what we don't know and wanting
to make sure that we don't Implement
something that uh we find out later has
caused uh considerable cost or or um
inconvenience to the
um you know to these parties um I saw
your finger so I'll let you have a
dialogue I I just remembered something
um folks may recall the department ofy
employment no not employment department
of environmental services um came in
with a concern that they've got uh air
quality testing equipment that is uh
very high quality very high tech very
expensive um however it's made overseas
and so it would not U meet the OSHA um
uh uh certification requirements um
because of if if we went with option
option one um they they would probably
be um required to replace that equipment
with um OSHA certified equipment if we
went with option two it would allow um
the department to or allow the
Department of Labor to um effectively
certify that equipment as at least
effective and at least as effective and
um they could continue using it um
so when the unknowns happen um and when
uh uh the other example that was used
during our
meeting was rather interesting it was
was it exitor yeah um exitor has a town
um building town hall
probably that is very
historic um and um the
uh the entrance door is a big thick Oak
wooden door um OSHA would not approve
that door as being a fire door um in
order to be approved by OSHA with a
Bonafide fire door it has to be um you
know certain standards and it has to
have a plate attached to it um labeling
it as oosha
or as as a fire door um apparently if
you paint over that um that label uh it
is no longer a certified um fire door um
if you remove the label even though it's
the same door it's no longer a certified
fire door um certainly these oakd doors
don't have labels don't have any um uh
would not be deemed certified fire doors
but uh the department um suggests and I
would have to U trust their expertise
that um those o oak doors would serve as
fire doors um and the town of exitor
would not have to put um a a new
upgraded very uh modern uh fire door on
a building that's very historic in doors
you know replacing doors that are
themselves very historic um so the air
testing equipment the oak fire doors um
are examples of
um things that happened in New Hampshire
that uh OSHA wouldn't be happy about um
and
um I think the anticipation is going to
what chairman infantine said um the um
as towns and departments and various all
the public entities in the state have
the department come in and say can you
do a review for us can you give us an
idea where we stand um
other examples of like the oak doors May
pop up um might be dramatically
different from that but there just might
be other issues that OSHA wouldn't like
but um the New Hampshire Department of
Labor could say this is as effective as
the OSHA um
certified whatever and um so it puts the
department in a position to to to
um determine whether or not things that
are going on in the counties and the
schools in the towns um in the agencies
whether um they're as effective or need
um in my opinion um option two probably
is the direction we I would suggest we
head uh um but um I'd be happy to hear
uh from other members of the committee
as to what their thoughts are and
hopefully I've talked long enough so
the uh thank you Mr chairman
um which part would allow the um
commissioner to make those types of
um the the very first paragraph employer
shall provide employees a level of
protection that is at least as effective
so those words are what allows the um
Department to make a judgment as to
whether or not the
safety
um
uh environment within a particular
public entity is at least as effective
um with without those words it would
have to be exactly the same as OSHA
standards
thank thank you um couple things
Hillsboro also has a big old door in um
our library so um that I think would
also apply one of the things that was
brought to my attention over the last
couple weeks is that um OSHA has a
specific standard for the Marine
um people that Patrol marine and
anybody's working out in the waters
uh so and I have not gone through our
1910 standard to see how we're
addressing that in our 1910 or if it is
even addressed my understanding from the
conversation and I'm okay being
corrected if I misunderstood is that
1910 does not address the Marine
standards but that there is a specific
OSHA regulation that does and given our
um Marine Patrol and other um public
entities that operate on our Waters I
think we should consider that as well as
and I guess I would looked to the
department I I know that um
uh attorney Gardner um went through this
in
um you know minute detail so I are you
familiar with whether or not 1910 has
marine or whether the other there are
two other sections of oosha standards
that uh perhaps
May so yes thank you for the question um
so as I understand it again as we talked
about 1910 is General Industry so
there's probably some pieces that will
go to some of the Marine aspects of it
and if I remember correctly I believe
it's either 1926 1928 or there is
another set of standards as well that is
very very detailed as to um you know
Marine aspects um so again to your
specific question I think there's some
pieces that would be applicable in the
1910s again just being General Industry
um but if the committee wanted to
actually drill down and get to more very
specific standards it might have to look
at um the other sections of Osha in
later
you I question
sure so in in terms of Staffing um which
was mentioned in one of the proposals
the increase in
Staffing uh can you can you give me a
sense
of where what you're looking to do in
terms of Staffing and the other question
I have is that there was some I was
reading an audit of the D I think it a
year or two ago um and they talked about
the shifting costs and the workers comp
and I think there was some issue around
how much of of the Department's
responsibility was being moved over to
the
compend
um so I don't know where the money is
coming from to do this uh but it seemed
to me in reading that audit report there
were some limitations as as shifting
some of these costs over to uh because
the the way the do is is is uh
structured is there there are kind of
petitions between uh the way that the
administrative fund the comp fund and
other things like that so tell me how
that's going to work and and if you
could also give me a sense
of of what you think you would need and
uh given and I don't know how many
workplaces there are in New Hampshire um
but maybe give us a sense of how this
would work and uh if we're going to do
it we should do it the best we can I
guess no sorry from the last meeting and
quote me if I'm wrong I think it was
like 250 municipalities I believe that's
what the commissioner Focus so it's
about 250 M municipalities plus
depending on how you count State um at
agencies about 40 State
agencies um so for option one which is
what I call the holistic adoption of
1910 um wholesale adoption over the
course of three years we're thinking
just because it's a wholesale adoption
um that and that there'll be confusion
and a need for additional inspections um
during that threeyear time frame where
the inspectors are going to go in
they're going to be basically doing
double inspections one for current
compliance and one for where they need
to be in three years we're thinking they
we'll need 12 staff members plus maybe
one additional administrative staff
member person um currently our
inspectors our safety inspectors are
labor grade
22 uh entry level with no experience uh
50,45976
if we kept it at that same labor grade
which I'm not sure if we would uh we
haven't had that level of discussion but
if we talk about that plus benefits the
lower-end benefit package that we try to
um estimate would be employee plus one
cost $3 31,725 in addition to their um
their wages so uh so it's about
$100,000 per uh employee for for the uh
inspectors um so that's option one we
are looking into whether or not
contractors is something that might be
looked you know applicable to here um we
don't know what the cost is for that um
as well as the requirement you know how
you can oversee the work of a contractor
that's not something the department has
done before we have a very very limited
contract line now um uh in the amount in
by mean by Limited in funds uh so that
something that we would be willing to
explore as well with respect to to
making those staffing needs um so that's
option one option two given the fact
that we're going to be controlling the
language and the accessibility of the uh
rules that we be adopting U because
they're going to be equivalent to OSHA
but the wording would be different we're
not adopting all of the federal uh 1910
standards it would be only things that
are applicable um we think that you know
the training oh sorry let me go back to
training for an inspector under current
standards for our safety inspectors
takes about 6
months to get them into you know on
their own out on the road able to assess
and do a complete inspection um I'm
thinking with a federal o that'll take
about a year to get them up to speed um
and again we've never done this before
so that this is an estimate uh and then
so for so that to keep that in mind as
well with respect to how quickly we can
get them up to speed and on the road uh
for the option two because they'll be
more accessible I don't think training
will take as long and we will still need
more inspectors on the road just because
more more regulation means more
inspectors it's more babysitting of a
case observing and getting into current
compliance so I'm thinking six
inspectors plus one additional
administrative staff member the problem
with both plans though just so you're
aware one of the things to be aware of
we have very limited sta uh sorry very
limited space within the Department of
Labor's building currently I
our safety inspectors I can barely fit
the three positions I have now uh we
would need to rent additional space to
house additional staff um and we can I I
can't speak directly to the costs where
you know where the budget would be
access
okay before you start I'd like to
publicly uh congratulate at uh um you on
your elevation to the Deputy
Commissioner thank you I very much
appreciate that I'll do my best um I'm
Danielle Albert I'm the Deputy
Commissioner of the Department of Labor
I will do my best to answer the question
um relative to where the funding would
come from what the department has
proposed uh with both proposals whether
it's the wholesale adoption or the um as
as effective as option the funding
stream would come through uh primarily
two mechanisms it would be through the
administ fund that set forth through 281
a59 um I think that's what was referred
to as the insurance carrier uh
assessment
uh which is through the workers
compensation statute which includes the
uh safety Provisions that come along
with workers compensation there are
certain safety requirements set forth in
the workers comp statute that require
employers to provide safe workplace
environments such that you can minimize
uh and reduce the costs associated with
workplace injuries and through the
restricted fund which is where the other
revenues that the department brings in
come through uh there is discretion in
the language for the commissioner to
determine how to abortion uh that
funding but that those would be the
funding mechanisms that the department
would be looking at with either option
whether it's the enhanced number of
Staff needed for a wholeale adoption or
whether the um somewhat reduced number
of staff that would be needed for the as
likely as
option and is it fair to say that um
neither option would have an impact on
the general fund I think it's possible
and I'm not certain that this point that
I would be um accurate in trying to
quantify that I I think it would depend
possible thank you um so early on in
when we met in the subcommittee there
was conversation about uh Federal
funding that we could apply for if we go
to the ocean standards I'm assuming that
if we were to go to option number two
that that Federal funding wouldn't be
available because it's going to be your
own Department making the rule making I
believe that to be accurate and I'll
defer to attorney Gardner if I'm not to
clarify option one and option two would
give us no federal funding what you're
referring to is the OSHA state plan
which requires adoption of all OSHA
standards and as we discussed at the
committee you're referencing um that's a
very very lengthy process that's in
conjunction with OSHA so neither option
would get us any federal funds
let me ask let me ask you see the
Department's going to return based on a
statement that you made uh I think last
week that the department will send back
to the to the rainy day fund some $3
million this year um this is in addition
to the two plus million they sent back
in the past now the stream for that
money is that available in any way for
the this kind of work and either in the
from thank you for the question the the
give back provision or the give back
that the department is making this year
roughly 3 million and the amount prior
was I believe 2 million um comes from
the revenue that the department takes in
primarily through its civil penalty
assessment AC
that involves both insurance carriers as
well as through the labor laws that are
currently codified um the funding the
the amount that gets brought in is
dependent it's dependent upon a couple
of things it's dependent upon insurance
carrier compliance it's dependent upon
employer compliance and how many
violations uh on either side under 281a
or under 275 uh 276 and all the other
labor statutes that um come about um it
fluctuates if you look at the history of
what the department has turned back over
to the general fund an excess Revenue in
that context it it has changed from year
to year um but it comes from the excess
Revenue that we're taking in primarily
actions I think it I I believe it to be
and I will correct if I am inaccurate
that it could be I would note that given
that there is some
inconsistency dependent upon what the
department has come across within the
preceeding um year or so that the amount
fluctuate oh no worries I my no worries
at all thank you I also know that the
commissioner in our meeting last week
indicated that he was going to check to
find out what the procedure would be for
accessing those funds for this purpose
has he had a chance to do that at this
point I don't I do not believe that we
have't answer thus far okay thank
questions so so there was a question
about um writing a new standard and then
getting it through jail car so what's
the expectation um that you're going to
drop pages and pages of of revisions on
on that committee um and if that doesn't
go through this whole thing goes down
basically doesn't work correct meaning
of the option to sector doing it via the
ru do either one you'd have to go in
front of Joe for yes if option two were
the option that uh ultimately ended up
going forward it would be subject to the
same requirements that any form of
rulemaking would go through meaning that
it has to go through that jail car rule
making process and finally approved by
jail car I would note that I think
historically the department has had very
good success in drafting its rules uh
and has not had T difficulty typically
having them pass through jail car but
they would be subject to that that level
of review and final Jael car
thank you Mr chairman um I need to
follow up on
that because we have all these wonderful
things called rules and
laws so we pass a law that says
X aren't am I correct that your rule
making that would go to jel car is just
explaining how you're going to enforce
them it is not adopting an entire
package of because if this
committee passes a bill and it gets
passed and signed by the governor we
have a law that says again we don't know
what it's look like but pretty good idea
of what it would look like and it would
would would State a lot of the details
associated with
1910 so J car doesn't have to approve
1910 correct they're just approving your
implementation of 1910 yes
representative infantine I think that's
an accurate uh statement the the
statutory language if it went into
effect would give the department
rulemaking Authority um and sets that
tone of the requirement that there be
rules out that there be that the
department is implementing standards
that are at least as effective um as the
ocean 1910 standards Provisions uh the D
through Z the exception of subpart U um
it's not the rules
themselves and I'm not certain if that
answered your question so was that last
but it's not the rules themselves so the
statute's not mandating the language and
the rules themselves it does give the
authority to the department to then
promulgate those rules the rules would
be promulgated or written with the eye
towards 1910 as that guide post as
representative Sullivan had explained
incorporating the portions that are
necessary for for New Hampshire's public
municipality School District state
agencies um Those portions would then be
going through that final Jael car
approval process thank you I just wanted
to make sure you everyone understood
that the entire 1910 doesn't get
approved by J car it's just their rules
about implementation of that would be
correct and um could you envision at in
some places uh saying the 1910 um
standard is written in a manner that we
want to adopt and just use the OSHA uh
language as is would you anticipate
doing that in some
instances it would if if the assessment
were that what was necessary that is
something that could be done I don't
know at this juncture whether or not
that would be necessary given that we're
not in that spot as of right now um but
I do not believe that there would be
anything in the proposed language for
that section option that would preclude
or prevent the department from saying
this section of 1910 um is exactly the
rule that the department requires in
order to enforce a certain type of
safety standard throughout the state of
New Hampshire and taking or utilizing
that language wholesale
okay and I'll look at at attorney
Gardner in case I've misspoken on that
no no I obviously agree with Deputy
Commissioner Albert um and just a kind
of point of clarity here each option
here as of the effective date would
require all employers subject to this
chapter to provide um safety that's at
least as effective as section 1910 so to
your question representative McKenzie um
you know say for example that the rule
Mak doesn't go through um obviously I
think that's problematic in the sense
that we all want employers to understand
what standards they're being held to and
that's the uh point of the rul making
provision but again as of the date of
the effective date of either of these
bills the employers would be required to
provide that level of protection so it's
not a matter of if the rul making
doesn't go through for say ladders then
there's nothing on ladders it's just a
reference to 1910 versus an explicit um
explanation and rul
making something that wasn't immediately
clear to me on this um I'm glad I'm
thinking of this because is a question
we needed to get
out um can you describe how the um
replacement of current um standards with
the new standards as you do with Ru
making would would it be a situation
where the the rules stay in the rul
making process is effectively sort of a
rolling replacement of current standards
yes I think that would be accurate to
State um as testified to previously the
intent with this would be not just
merely the three-year plan but an annual
review to see if there's any updated
standards that might be applicable to
New Hampshire employers as well so again
um just going forward there would be an
annual review of all standards to make
sure that uh they make sense and we're
providing safety that's at least as
effective as section 1910 because
because one of the issues that um we'
identified I think two weeks ago was
that um if the uh if the bill calls for
the repeal of all current department of
labor standards in the eventual
replacement it would leave a vacuum for
a period of time which we don't want
that's correct the caveat being that um
again the first section of each of these
bills would require employers to provide
that level of protection but it it hurts
Clarity so essentially the current the
current standards would remain in place
until the rulemaking process um you know
in bits and pieces over the next three
years um replaces the current standards
with um at least as effective standards
correct any current standards in place
the department would review in light of
the 1910 standards determine if there
needs to be an update to those and then
obviously anything that's silent we
would determine how far we need to go
with those standards what we need to
implement for New Hampshire employers so
option two does not um requ uh need a
section that talks about repealing
because the rulle making process itself
effectively does the repealing I think
that would be correct to State and
obviously if there's anything that the
department found through the rul making
process process or review of our
standards whether it's uh again rules we
would update through the JL car process
if it's something that's statutory we
would bring it to the legislature um and
advise that there might need to be an
okay thank you Mr chairman just for the
record for some of the members of the
committee
um has letters a through z right we are
excluding A and B A is general b is
adoption of extension of establishing
Federal standards and C currently is
blank it's reserved right we also do not
have they do not have
subparts vwx and Y so I just want to
make sure we we we uh we amend
the to not include those because they're
reserved so what I don't want to happen
is next uh a bill passes here a year
from now uh ocean decides they want to
include a new section V well if we
include in our laws it's automatic so I
want to exclude make sure we do exclude
U which is the co part uh vwx and Y
which are reserved in blank so just so
you know what the the A through Z are if
you want you can see this
outline one of the things that we
discussed in the meeting um which I
always enjoy getting up at 6:15 in the
morning and watching the sunrise over
the mountains of Arizona but it was it
was fine um I got to see a Road Runner
that morning hey so hey it was worth it
uh you know how big a Road Runner
is not that though not like you know you
think on TV with the coyote and whatever
um so one of the things we discussed was
kind of a
misnomer that the Department is supposed
to review rules um regarding safety and
update them every two years that is not
accurate okay it is every 10 years um
and and it's that's important
because um I will tell you I think door
number one the wholesale adoption um
what I'm always afraid of um
representative suoman is um things that
we don't know you know we've been here
long enough you and I and a number of
people here on this committee have been
here long enough to know that what we do
when we sit here and pass a piece of
legislation
um sounds good we think we're doing the
right thing and then it gets out into
the real world and sometimes we find
that it needs a little
tweaking
um but again we don't want to perfect
get in the way of getting something done
so I would rather move if anything with
with uh option two you're talking six
employees versus 12 you have a situation
where you don't have a place to house
the employees as it is having to get it
through a second committee on finance
the goal is to get something passed
there's no goal in getting something
passed through the house which is not
going to get passed by the Senate and
and implemented
so option two has a better chance of
getting that
done
um my desire
which sounds good to me but probably
not easy to implement
is option
of well we talking you know what I'm
gonna say talking about in the telephone
go ahead um option three which is why
don't you just update your standards to
things you want to
do okay you have a standard that is in
place right
now right hasn't been updated maybe
eight or 10 years
so what I want to do is take some of the
things that are most important through
from a through
z and Implement those the problem as
it's been expressed to me by staff
is there will be contradictions between
possibly the current rules and laws and
some of these these um in
1910 I'm not saying I have the
answer um to to what that is because I
am an idiot and I have read a lot of
this
stuff um and I can tell you I've been in
in the insurance business for 30 years
and I'm OA 10
certified and I don't even know how to
read some of this
stuff okay so let alone some of the
things that some of the municipalities
are going to have to find someone to
train or whether we're going to have to
have a train the trainer people someone
from the Department of Labor um so I'm
trying to implement this slowly as you
have agreed to in in a two or threee
period which I'm thankful and appreciate
I appreciate you doing that um because I
just don't want to make some of these
mistakes because I don't want someone
coming in front of us saying well you
know those oak doors even though we put
a little thing on them or whatever yeah
it's still not going to work it's still
not and um so I'm fearful of the unknown
but not so fearful that I don't want us
to do
something so uh you don't have me at
hello but you had me at least better
funny I'm not that funny so when I have
so so at least um looking at number two
and starting there but that that's
really my only concern representative
suoman is is implementing
stuff there was a bill you you were not
here uh at the time a bill passed the
house and the Senate and was signed by
the governor out of this
committee that was so
bad that we had to go back the first
week of January and repeal
it
um requiring everyone to have workers
compensation regardless of whether
you're uh an employer or not employee or
owner or not um we we kind of rejiggered
and now that any state funded project
everyone on the site has to have it so
you know we solved it in a certain way
um but yeah I mean Governor Lynch had to
yank us all in the first week of January
and and and repeal it um so I I just
don't want to do something where we have
that because there's been it has been
too long since there's been some updates
it's I can't sit
here in my profession and say we
shouldn't be
safer that would be
foolish so I I'm I I'm between option
two which I am happier with and then
option three so please for the record
for everybody else here why uh option
three or I'm going to call it door
number
three
um could B probably be too problematic
to
implement may I yeah sure you're the
you're the chairman
um in my former life I dealt with
schools and school boards and
superintendents and um one of the things
that I observed is the superintendent
would often um be very careful to say I
don't do policy the school board does
that the school board is the
decision-making
body and then a good superintendent
would steer that school board into
making good decisions that the
professional
educator helps them with um I see that
that has kind of happened here um the
department I mean we are the policy
makers we were that was stated at our
meeting last week by the
commissioner um that is true you you are
not the policy makers we
are keep that
straight
however um then the department went and
developed an option that
um I mean they never said so um you can
if you want um but I believe option two
is something that you feel is uh far
more um reasonable for the State of New
Hampshire than um the wholesale adoption
um and on that basis and the fact that
you guys put it together if you put
something together that you can't do
shame on
you um so I'm going to believe that you
put something together that you firmly
believe the department can um Can
Implement that's what we asked you two
weeks ago to do we want a clean
implementation of this process and
um you put together option one because
that's pretty much where we were going
into um last week and then you gave us
option two which was a modification of
that that
um you know I think does what
representative infantine was talking
about it it allows the department to do
its thing to adopt New Hampshire
standards but it also provides a guide
through the 1910 standards to make sure
that we don't end up what we've got now
right now we've got standards but it's
full of gaps and we that was the um one
of the primary um objections to where we
are compared to where we want to go and
I believe this option to um
plan
um would fill fill those gaps it won't
fill any any gaps that don't need to be
filled um because you've got the
authority to skip over sections that are
not applicable
um but it does fill in all the gaps that
do apply to public sector um uh entities
in um New Hampshire um and so I for one
um would like to take the Department's
lead you did what we asked you to do
and you know I there will be some who
will be I'll tell you the downside to to
doing option two is that it does not
adopt the 1910 standards and it it would
make it more difficult down the road to
create a state plan the state plan as
representative Susi you know reminded us
comes with money Federal money um uh
option one puts us closer to adopting a
state plan somewhere down the road
option two leaves us with a lot of
um
uh state standards that will that won't
match 1910 they will be at least as
effective but they won't match but I
I I having said that I still think
option two is the way we ought to go um
because effectively it getss us to a
safer spot which is what we're trying to
do here um and if uh uh people down the
road 5 10 years from now want to do a
state plan um I say go for it but uh
that's not where we are now um so
um um I would entertain a motion if
unless there's further discussion that
we
need I would like further discussion
I'm not I'm not shutting it
down um
so option
two
four the commissioner shall have
authority to determine if standards are
inapplicable to employers and are
unnecessary to
implement representative salivan had
mentioned
mining okay I'm looking at a through z
here and I'm going to put you on the
spot and if you can't answer it no no
harm no
foul anything in
particular um I obviously you wouldn't
want to take out medical and first aid
you wouldn't want to take out fire
protection you wouldn't want to take
out uh Compressed Gas uh Material
Handling machinery and machining
guarding I mean I don't know which one
you'd take out that's what I'm trying to
say here as I look through um all of
these welding cutting and brazing you
know which
electrical driving so wouldn't
necessarily be take out it would be
simplify so for example and condense so
basically what I would be looking to do
is take that and this and try to figure
out a happy medium so for example the
lad section in 1910 and platform section
in
1910 are basically identical so we don't
need both sections whol adopted we can
combine the two so it would be making it
so that we're handing someone our new
rule book it's not the shock of 1100
Pages um so I don't know what it what is
going to end up being in the end but
it's going to be simplifying and
condensing um 1910 so it's more
accessible there isn't that fear of
oversaturation of rules uh where a
person is handed 1100 pages and says I'm
not even going going to read that tell
me what I need to do uh I want something
that someone looks at and says well I'll
at least give it a shot and
try um so that's that's you know so that
that is what we're looking at for when
it comes to a 1910 like adoption of our
rules um and just to address your
position uh representative Sullivan I
think so this plan option to is modeled
over the fame model it's the federal
annual um op annual mandatory
evaluations of Osha States so states
that are going they're trying to become
OSHA States so if becoming an OSHA state
in the future becomes a goal of New
Hampshire it's basically a different way
to get there we're already doing the
annual reviews that a Fame state does so
it's moving so it's a different way to
get there but I think it also is you
know doesn't close off an option we
already have that skeleton annual review
because OSHA they acknowledge that their
plan is not the best plan their any plan
that a state should adopt should be
something where every year is evaluated
and changed and and things are actually
getting looked at and addressed so so
there is so that so again I think it is
another way of meeting the same goal we
putting steps in place which OSHA would
like states that are looking to become
OSHA states to have so there's so again
it's just a different way of going at
the same goal um thank you I just wanted
to clarify
that let's talk about a timeline here
okay let's say this thing
gets um signed the loget signed by the
governor in June of
24 okay so in order to take this and
that and put it
together um let's look what what time
frame we're looking at
6 months a year so it's going to be a
same threeyear roll out so over time so
we're going and so unlike so when we
looked when the plans that we were
looked to that we were asked to try to
create an action plan initially was a
holistic approach or a peac meal
approach um so adopting 1910 as it reads
right now you can't adopt in a peacemeal
approach too many sections reference
each other so it will cause confusion
amongst the municipalities so we're
adopting provision C but that references
something sorry not c d but that
references something in E so you know
what you know what still what what are
we adopting what are we ar what aren't
we would be a question that we would
have to constantly explain to the public
employers uh if we did a peace meal
adoption of 1910 as it reads with the
option two that we're talking about here
we can do a peace meal because again
it'll be rolling rule adoption um over
the course of the 3 years to
minimize the sticker shock uh you know
the cost to towns so they can do they
can budget and plan and roll things out
in piece in stages as opposed to now six
months you need to be in full compliance
with
1910 um so it is a three-year rollout
plan we'll be evaluating rules the
initial plan would be to fill in the
gaps that we do not address currently in
our 1400 rules then look at where we can
strengthen the things that we already
speak to would be plan this would be the
second stage of the three-year rollout
plan and and I would point out that in
in section four um Roman four uh the
last sentence indicates that it's um
these standards would be at least as
effective within three years from the
passage of this act so that's what sets
up the three-year um
timeline understood Mr chairman I just I
need to be kind of a little more
specific I on a timeline and and I'm not
trying to harp but I just need to
mentally understand this because I'm
sure it'll be asked of
me it's get it gets implemented it gets
passed in June you have six months to
try to figure something out because then
you have to present it you know the
world needs to see it right okay and
then you still have two and a half years
and you can do your as you you described
earlier a pencil audit going into
to these places to see where they don't
meet the new rules so the pencil audits
start from the passage so for me so
that's how I I'm so so you don't have
your your thing yet correct so we'll be
looking at it and saying what's not at
least as effective and things that we'll
be addressing down the line but in the
meantime but they won't be held
accountable to that it it's like these
are our current standards this is what
we've currently set and this is where
your efficient and with current
standards you have to get it to current
standard code but in the meantime this
is where we're leading so please start
budgeting for that um because my
inspectors are going to be the ones
helping me draft these rules in
conjunction with our legal unit um so
they'll know what's to come so they've
already started writing now um
so so that'll be the plan as we we all
already know what's in the distance so
we can start informing the general
public and the the the stakeholders to
municipalities public employers uh then
we'll have our annual meetings which we
will be proposing our changes in advance
so to let them know these are the
changes that are going to be coming in
and we're going to be proposing to jel
car and have their open have the public
session for them to speak about what any
concerns there could be another town of
exit or issue that we didn't foresee we
knew about town of exit because we we've
recently inspected them um Dees that was
something that we learned of at this
meeting we didn't know about how their
air quality machines would be impacted
by a 1910 roll out so that's where I
anticipate the stakeholders bringing up
their concerns so that we don't adopt
something that would make New Hampshire
less safe uh or less reasonable with
respect to our safety standards and and
you actually have it's not six months
that you have to write rules it's three
years you have so essentially um you can
start writing rules immediately start
cheating them into Jael car and um and
you've got a three-year period of time
to get get the job completely done and
have all of your rules um at least as
effective that's the plan yes and but
with there being peace meal adoption of
our rules over time so it's not year
three learn that so that that's the plan
the I'm saying this kind of jokingly
politely
I would not recommend saying again
sticker shock um in in in your testimony
because that's the big concern that some
of us have we don't know what the cost
is going to be yet and we don't know the
cost we might be passing on I live in
the city of Manchester I can tell you
that they they're scratching their heads
at some of the departments in Manchester
with the Department of uh um Parks and
Rec and and what this is going to do to
them and when they ask me I can't tell
them what the costs are going because
again we're just getting down
to option two here versus the initial
option one so that is a
concern um the the the the the cost so
option two would not have the and I have
the
nrtl so this is the I had already
provided copies to both representative
Sullivan and infantine of what is
required to be nrtl approved so wherever
there is an equally safe option to nrtl
approval we would not be adopting that
so the you know the solid oak doors is
an exitor those are effective even if
not more so than what they construct
today for fire doors um so is something
where we would maintain our reasonable
standard on option two that we would
lose in option one a whole sale adoption
of
1910 I'm sorry we're lost
okay thank you you don't
no you you were in Arizona that's right
lucky me
H what you have a question D
yep I did just what I just passed out
was what um um you were just referring
refering to the um the list of um nrtl
approved things and um I think that's
that sort of led us into the oako
discussion as I recollect um
representative
kcom thank you um I guess I I'd like to
go back and um revisit my question
regarding the the Marine Patrol fishing
game and those um public entities that
work on the waters and how they're going
to
be affected by what we're changing so
are they currently covered under our
standards in the state so we're 1910
does not cover that 1926 or 28 does how
how are they going to be impacted by
what we're doing
here I I have to look at it because um
currently uh the ports I believe so are
what is impacted under 1910 but have to
double check that it's been a little
while since I look directly at the
Mar um because again it's so infrequent
that we have a very I think it's just
one location where it would be really
impacted well two locations um so it
doesn't come up very often so I'd have
to look at it as I believe there's a
port also in addition to um your uh the
the uh the Marine control that would be
impacted so think just two public
employers really that it would Branch
into so I have to look into that and
find out oh um okay thanks what about
fishing game where they're working on
our Lakes they would fall under us yes
they would fall under the standards
right now they they they are are there
any specific Marine standards no um so
it ALS it would be a general duties but
they do fall under it as a Public
Employee yes all public employ sorry
public employers all fall under our
statutes currently is there anything
specific to them no what about the fire
departments and the local municipalities
that have boats that go out and um they
may go out and tend to people who are
drowning or accident cor they all fall
under us there's nothing specific to
Marine time Marine so will they be
impacted by this change there would be
that the uh there are various uh
organizations in the state prisons being
one of them that has a National Standard
that they follow the National Standard
uh and I don't think they're covered by
oosha um prisons
correct so how do you accommodate that
the public employees they're in this
environment you're passing rules do you
exempt them and I think their nursing
homes are very similar to that as well
so currently they do follow nursing
homes and the prisons we were in there a
couple months ago uh do fall under our
jurisdiction um so where they fall under
both Federal standards so it's you know
usually again right now the federal
standards are more protective in the
sense that they're more specific to what
our laws state so it it is you know
because our current laws were based off
of Osha a long time ago so it is so it's
basically the skeleton of what they have
today so it's just more detailed so they
are already basically if they are
following the federal standards which
apply to them they're under they're at
least as protective as our current
standards and it wouldn't necessarily
impact and either plan wouldn't impact
them currently now if now where the
issue was where the dees issue um
Environmental Services theirs they have
a state so their Federal grant money is
contingent upon them complying with all
state and federal laws so for us for
them currently they are following their
state mandate safety laws so if we were
to adopt 1910 Hol sale and they weren't
they didn't replace their current
Machinery which is at least as effective
as 1910 they would lose their Federal
funding because they're not they
wouldn't be then in compliance with
state
law what you looking at me
for no I I think Mr avalani I had a cut
just a couple other quick questions um
I'm interested in um
particular uh how it is that you train
people to deal with very serious
accidents serious death uh
accents now OSHA has a pretty robust um
organization uh and they bring a lot of
resources to uh you know to the scene
when they have when something happens or
when somebody lose a loss of life of
major
casualty
um so how do you how do you rep
replicate that
capacity and does it make more sense to
yield to oer in cases like that so right
now we're not an OSHA state so we
wouldn't there and OSHA does not
wouldn't come in currently there is no
yielding OSHA is not showing up um so
what we do now is very similar to um so
I I I'm a former prosecutor so we did
you know again um fatalities and and
things negligent homicide investigations
and such which I oversaw we handle very
similar to that in that we are
investigating I mean we're interviewing
Witnesses we're obtaining statements uh
for witness is to the um event we are
finding out what the current standards
and procedures are what is the training
that's being provided did they adhere to
that training is that training
sufficient uh if there's if it led to a
crime in which accident reconstruction
is show up we request their reports so
we look at their reports right and to
determine what is Aur you know what did
they they determin happened and led to
that injury um you that is similar how
we you know and so that is how we handle
it it's very similar to you know and I
think it is similar to where OSHA is we
utilize the resources that the state
already has I don't know if OSHA would
show up with accident reconstructionists
I've never seen that when we do have
OSHA cases that intersect with ours um
it is an investigator that shows up very
similar to mine and is taking witness
statements um and they are also filing
you know subpoenas for the you know
local police acent reconstructions if it
if they did occur you know if one
occurred um so we you know what we do is
very similar
um to what I think OSHA would do based
on just my limited experience of dealing
with cases in which there was a both a
public and private employer involved in
the serious
injury and if if I'm not mistaken um
even if we were in OSHA State the
department of labor would still be the
um entity that would be responsible for
all of the you know maintaining OSHA
standards correct um and I think that U
you know under no circumstances could o
OSHA ever show up on a public sector
workplace and um be taking over for the
Department of Labor that's not what a
correct you do have the option to work
with them there's nothing that prohibits
you right now yeah just as much as
they're willing to work with us that's
the only thing it prohibits okay so you
could potentially draw on them and say
come and help us and no so they won't
come in and help us right now um so when
we have instances where our
jurisdictions intersect and they are
already doing a report sometimes we can
request their report too there are
instances in which they will not share
them with us um but you know if we you
know we try to maintain a relationship
with them such that they are comfortable
sharing their work product with us and
vice versa but there's nothing mandating
it thank you one final question it's
involved reports uh the the current
situation is that they the employeers
were required to file first the um the
plan initially as I understand it so
they had to come up with their safety
plan and they have to file that has to
be on in uh in the department somewhere
that was changed they used to do it
every year they changed that so now they
but they do every two years they file an
up a no so that was taken so there there
was an update to the state to the
statutes which they do not they just
have to file a safety summary not their
full plan with us once um and there are
they are required to review their safety
plan uh every two years so that when we
do do inspections both a wage and hour
inspection and a safety inspection
inection with both public and private
sectors we do as part of our standard
requests ask to look at their safety
plan to see if it has been updated
within last two years so is there
anything we need to do uh in that area
as we go through this transition to make
sure that they are they're complying or
updating um I I don't believe so both
would require them to maintain and
update every two years I'll double check
that but I don't think that
changes thank
you
thank you um are they required now to
keep track of their recordable incidents
they have to report to you on an annual
basis what their recordables are and so
under there's two statutes so
281 2 RSA 281 A- 53 requires all
employers both public and private to
report all injuries regardless of
severity to the department within 5 days
of that injur or alleged injury sorry
alleged injury from um whether you know
to the department uh they can do that
either directly to us or via their
carrier even if they choose to go via
their carrier they're supposed to report
that to us my safety inspectors farm
that data when they before they go out
for an just a regular inspection even a
complaint generated inspection they're
looking at that data to see what their
injury rate what are they seeing most
commonly at that employer's location the
other statues
27715 littleb that one requires all
public employers to report serious
bodily injuries so injuries or death so
at a minimum injuries requiring an
overnight stay in a hospital to the
department for which for which we would
look at analyze and determine whether or
not a you know an investigation needs to
take
place follow so that sorry that has to
be done uh within oh gosh I think it's
24 hours for a death and or eight hours
for the death and 24 hours but there is
a time frame that's much shorter than
the 5 days sorry Sor right so if I
wanted to report of all of the accidents
that happened in the Department of Labor
last year would I be able to get that
from the data that you guys are
collecting a report for all of the
incidents that happened last year all in
So within a certain department so we can
um oh a certain Department yes you can
we can generate um because we do each
one is saved via code um now will it be
you know specifically detailed we would
then go in and you know if we need to
and read them but yes so gener like you
would see all the lower back injuries
just right just statistical data numbers
discussion thank you Mr chairman um some
of this is in 277 that are already in
law some of this will be in your rules
should we look at more having less rules
and more of it stated within the
statutes that way people are clearer on
what they need to follow and whatnot
instead of having whole wholesale 1400
become a behemoth and then have the
specific I mean there's both would have
the same you know rules have the effect
of law there are laws um I I think it's
I'm not I think they they could both get
ch same place one just takes longer it
would it also be true that if um if it's
in rules and the oosha standards get
adjusted you have the authority
immediately to um adjust your rules
rather than have wait for a new statute
you motion I want to talk about a time
our schedule here first okay right we
have to report everything out by
Thursday November 2nd correct sounds
great so we have um to
have one last final meeting to discuss
our four or of the labor committee to
discuss the four bills we have to vote
them in exact session correct yep right
and it is kind of my opinion um that we
should have the entire committee
here to have an opportunity to
understand I don't know I'm thinking out
loud
here if we have our exec session prior
to executing this bill I think you're
going to need some kind of it's going to
take there's going to be a lot of
questions I'm guessing by the entire
committee
so we have something we pick a date for
the executive session back back it up an
hour prior to that
to have the discussion on this one in
particular the other ones everyone knows
how they're going to vote already for
right they all agree Y and the other
three bills that we have in front of us
and and the labor committee everyone's
going to everyone pretty much knows you
have an amendment coming in you know so
everything's going to be pretty simple
on the three of them we you and I have
gotten into this a lot more the
committee has gotten into it a little
further some of our other members don't
have a clue what we've been up to we
take it um so I'm just looking at the
Timeline here as to what you want to do
now I was I would wanted initially to do
this the 26th Thursday the 26th yeah but
that but now we have veto day um so we
don't know that pardon well because we
don't know you know we only have what
five bills right you know um we don't
know how long the Senate's going
to I heard I heard somebody um suggest
that we ought to be done by three
three I I think that's being very
generous I think so good because we're
waiting how many are on the Senate we
have to wait for the
Senate
yeah so do you want to do it after or do
it has to be the day before be getting
people up here on the 25th and I don't
think people want to be here two days uh
I'm not sure we're going to have
everything prepared by the 19th
um to do it next Thursday with everybody
what's looking for some comments in
everybody
here the
beach not going to be here next week
you you do do ask people to come to
24th on Monday Monday
what
23rd I can do that I don't know what do
minute like 2 o' do that
for an exec session no no I'm talking on
Monday you don't want to do you want to
do the exec session on Thursday and a
preview on Monday
correct I was hoping to do them the same
day that see I would I would rather have
people come in here at at 10 o'clock in
the morning have one hour of discussion
on the OSHA thing and then at 11 o'clock
we start our executive
session that would work with me frankly
you could build the whole thing into EXA
session just leave a lot of time for the
ocean correct right uh um I was hoping
to do it only an hour before just so um
if people could really some people won't
show up some people aren't going to Care
some of the ones really want to dig into
it that's we're going to want to have
full 20 we'll have to have 20 people
here for an exact session right right so
people aren't showing up no but I'm
talking about doing it if they wanted to
what I don't want to do is I don't want
an hour and a half long exec session
just on this bill it would be nice if we
got to exec session we did what we're
supposed to do in exec session it last
15 or 20 minutes and get it done so
that's why I wanted to have something as
a
preview before then and I was hoping to
do it an hour before versus aning people
up here twice we want to do
it well I'm not uh Mark we're looking at
everything I'm looking at every day
okay
Tuesday the
31st uh getting
close come in
costume oh yeah I guess
legislator we have I have employment uh
Advisory
Board
yeah so it have to be the 31st or the
previous week how about the 20 we we're
we're in the 23rd for a bit correct 23rd
saying no Mark and I have something
Board see I don't want to yank people up
here in the how about okay well talk
among yourselves a little bit
25th uh the day before in the afternoon
52 the afternoon
yes 25th in the afternoon um for exec
session
bills I know we're going to have a
caucus prior to the 26th at 3 o'cl
so I hate to drag our whole committee
cus how about the
24th later
24th in the afternoon for executive
that all right I'm going to go with the
24th what what time Leo afternoon one
o'clock okay
two one o' gets me I it's an hour and 10
minutes puts me outside lunch two o'
gets me that's why I was asking you what
time you said
afternoon two okay
24th that will be our exec session for
all four
remaining and two o' two o'clock will be
the presentation
by discussion of otion yeah and then 3
fine
what I would like however is to have a
recommendation from this committee going
in so um I think at this point it would
be um uh appropriate to have a motion
from the subcommittee to uh um to do
something and I would suggest the motion
should be to to adopt option
two and and before we get to that exec
session obviously we need an official
Amendment but uh I think I think what
we've got now drafted by the department
of labor attorneys um is specific enough
and I expect that OS will just dress it
up in their format um so I don't I it's
not going to be much
different um representative Sullivan I
will support your
motion subject to seeing obviously the
amendment and I am going to discuss this
obviously with I have discussed this
with my leadership um option two and
some of things but to move it forward
um in the position here uh because I I
don't I would be voting against option
one at this point all right so uh I will
support option two subject to you know a
few caveats of seeing the
final
um um amendments and what have you
representative Susi do we have a
motion make it what you
said okay motion by um representative
Susi do we have a
second if you want
discussion you want to
see I yeah I just I I would hate to see
us wait for the uh the amendment but of
course um all bets are off if the
amendment comes up uh very different
from what we're talking about so thank
you Mr chair yep um are we ready to
vote we are
representative
kcam
yes representative McKenzie you're
actually not a voting member but I'm
Bard representative Susi
yes Mr chairman yes
Mr chairman yes so we have a unanimous
recommendation for the committee um I
would like to thank the committee I
would especially like to thank the
department and um I'm
uh uh encouraged with where we're at and
I I agree with uh representative
infantine that um this is something that
I believe we can um sell to the Senate
once we get it past our house of course
uh um but um I think we're moving in the
right direction so thank you
everyone before we leave we just said
this that in reading a recent uh press
release from the insurance department
your microphone's off congratulated
should be congratulated the Department
of Labor for the impact that the work
your work has had on the rates in New
Hampshire for the past uh 12 years the
rate has come down
63% so that's that's a major uh that was
the intent when this was passed to
reduce the uh injuries for people and to
reduce the rate for employers and this
is another step in that direction so
thank you for the work that you've done
over the years to make that happen thank
o'clock and welcome aboard
uh Miss Albert you'll it'll be a it'll
ride